It is time for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Now, we do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond to that topic.
So, since summer's coming up and schools are almost out,
I sent out the hashtag #WorstSummerJob.
And I asked you guys to tweet out a funny, weird,
or embarrassing story about a bad summer job you've had.
Within minutes, it was a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Applause ] And now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite #WorstSummerJob tweets from you guys.
This first one is from @anchorman43. They say...
[ Audience groans ]
-Ohh.
♪♪
Number one.
[ Laughter ]
-This next one is from @guesswho0603.
-Oh. -They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a terrible job.
This one is from @danielhudsonll. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?!
-This next one is from @AdamTCowart. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next one is from @TripleC50.
-Oh. -They say....
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one is from @MariaMesinger. She says...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our "Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.